starting off this hour is going to be
Katie in Alabama hi Katie welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey how's it going
better than I deserve what's up I have a
question my husband and I are in baby
steps too and we are trying to sell our
house it's been on the market since July
we did have a contingent contract but it
fell through in December we relisted
with me Realtors in January we've had
about 30 new families come through but
no offers yet we have dropped the price
significantly but we've been advised
that some updates and upgrades might
help
we're just wondering should we pause our
debt snowball to cashflow some of the
upgrades and cosmetic repairs or just
keep lowering the price while you're
sewing do we kind of made a dumb
decision and bought way too much house a
couple years ago our mortgage is about
40% of our take-home pay so we need to
need to get out of it and how much is it
on the market for um it is currently
listed for $5.99 what did it start at
back in the day when you first started
in July um in July we started at 695 so
W $100,000 yes and we purchased it for
640 so we did over price it event in the
beginning but when the jeweler that was
a big mistake
um we bought it in April of 2017 okay
yeah you had her over pricing and now
you probably got it priced correctly
what updates are they suggesting and
what are they cost um
kitchen appliances all the appliances
are original to our houses like in 1989
house doing some like landscaping we
need some new sod and those types of
things but the primary thing is the
kitchen I think you bought it two years
ago three years ago for 640 thousand
with those exact same things yep yes and
we've done a twenty thousand dollar
master bathroom renovation in the
meantime as well
I mean you bought it for six hundred and
forty thousand as is
right with the existing kitchen
appliances and with the current yard
condition unless the yards gone down
here while you owned it ya know it
hasn't really ya know we just we we
realize we ever paid for it about
ourselves - it was appraised for 648
though so yeah you know at the time it
didn't see my point is that those things
were not necessary for you to buy it
correct and that's making me think here
so what would you spend to do those
updates what do you have a budget on
that I mean considering kitchen
appliances just to do that probably
$5,000 more you spend on the sod I
honestly have no idea let's call it
$10,000 how much debt do you have left
80 mm mm-hmm
and what's your household only um around
a hundred thousand a year I think you
need to sell it as it is just keep
lowering the price and we're pretty
close to taking a loss at this point
you're already taking a loss over what
you paid for yeah yeah what do you owe
on it um we owe 547 down yeah you're
just barely gonna get out there huh I
would rather put 10,000 in it then put
10,000 right $10,000 of the mortgage
company because I didn't do the repairs
so if you want to stop and do them you
can do them it's kind of on the bubble
but I always question this because you
know it's always interesting to me the
realtor will jump in and take the
listing and give you the pricing and
then when they can't get it sold they
come back later and go well you should
do this it's like you know it's I always
want to look at them and go won't you do
your job and so freaking house you know
and so there's some of that but there is
some there's some reality to their
request to because you know maybe the
market is not as hot as it was when you
bought you know maybe people aren't
quite as quite as frenzied in their
buying as you were in the current you
know the current environment is a little
slower maybe than it was
17 that's very possible you know in your
area so and we've had some new
construction around us that may have
changed so you know but I think I would
set a reasonable low budget and get that
done really fast and then I would be up
in my Realtors grille and go get this
thing sold if I do this stuff you better
get it sold
mm-hmm you know now you know and so are
you working with one of our endorsed
local providers no we are not okay is if
the realtor you have is not selling 20
or 30 or 50 houses a year you probably
have the wrong realtor that's the other
thing because there's about 80% of
people that are real estate license know
how to put the stuff into the MLS and
put a sign in the yard and they think
that's marketing and the other 20% make
all the money and sell all the houses
it's the Pareto principle and it applies
in real estate 20 percent of the real
estate agents in America sell 80% of the
houses and so that's who you want to be
working with is someone in that category
I don't know if you are or not if you're
working with one of our LPS you would be
because we don't let people be in our LP
program or we endorsed them unless
they're high octane high producers and
that you might get a different answer
from that person rather than oh would
you fix this stuff so I can sell your
house it drives me nuts I understand it
could be true okay so you may need to do
it but you need to think about - do you
have the right realtor let's the other
question hey thanks for the call